It's really fucking shitty that women are surmising that
the reason why Ballerina Farm dropped out of Juilliard
in her senior year. She was like,
well, she knew she wasn't gonna be a good ballerina anyway,
so she was like, fuck it,
I'll just give up my dreams and go with this rich guy.
What kind of pick me anti woman shit is that?
And for your fucking information,
for the first few months in the same fucking article,
for the first few months after their marriage,
she still tried dancing. She was a professional dancer in Brazil
for the first few months of their life.
She was not trying to give up on her dream.
No, the fuck she wasn't.
She was absolutely fucking convinced.
It's called fucking love bombing
when you go from just having met
to being married within a few months of each other.
Wake the fuck up! Come on!
Just because you have a choice to do something
doesn't make it a good fucking choice.
Just because a guy is offering to give you this grand,
amazing fucking life, all you have to do in exchange is be his partner.
I mean, that seems like a big fucking exchange.
It seems like. It seems like it's maybe,
possibly too fucking good to be true.
And he's not gonna give you that fucking life.
When you're hoping for the trip to Greece,
you're gonna get a fucking egg apron.
Don't fall for, like,
if you wanna Get dressed up pretty and bake shit.
You can do that. And then you get to eat the shit
instead of giving it all to some man
who's never gonna fucking fully appreciate
all that you're giving to them.
You don't have. It's not a this or that.
You can be pretty and bake and do all kinds of shit.
You don't need to be somebody's fucking little personal servant.